Nos piden que grafiquemos la siguiente recta
"y" igual a1/3 de "x" menos 2
y bueno, siempre que veas a una recta de esta forma...
se le conoce con el nombre,
como recta pendiente ordenada al origen
es decir, cada vez que veas a una recta de la
forma "y" es igual a "mx" más "b"
vamos a pensar en que se llama
recta pendiente ordenada al origen, donde la pendiente es lo que está a lado de la "x" que es 1/3
y donde la ordenada el origen
es decir "b" es en este caso -2
y se llama ordenada al origen porque es el valor que toma "y" cuando sustituimos el valor de la "x" por 0
es decir, cuando "x" vale 0 este término
de aquí se anula y entonces
simple y sencillamente nos queda que "y" vale "b"
y es justo por eso que se llama ordenada al origen.
A la vez se le conoce como ordenada al origen y bueno, la forma de graficar este tipo de rectas
es una forma muy sencilla, porque
ya sabemos un punto,
el punto que nosotros sabemos es que
cuando "x" vale 0, entonces "y" vale -2,
entonces aquí en el eje las "y"
voy a pasar este punto que tengo aquí.
Cuando "x" vale 0 ,"y" vale -2
y no hay nada de mágico aquí
realmente lo único que puedes hacer
es sustituir este valor...
cuando yo pongo en esta ecuación el valor de
"x" igual a 0 entonces esto que está aquí se cancela
y solamente me quedaría que que "y" es igual a -2
y esto es lo que nos dice nuestra ordenada al origen.
Ahora hablemos de la pendiente, la pendiente
nos dicen que es 1/3
y realmente lo que nos dice la pendiente,
y déjame ponerlo aquí,
este 1/3 es la pendiente,
y cuando hablo yo de pendiente a lo que me refiero es
cuánto cambia "y" a comparación de
cuánto es lo que cambia "x"
es decir, el cambio de "y",
entre el cambio de "x",
esto quiere decir que cuando "x" cambia 3 unidades
entonces "y" va a cambiar 1unidad,
y bueno, ya sabemos que este punto el que
está en la ordenada al origen,
está en nuestra línea recta, y ahora
fíjate en lo siguiente...
si "x" cambia 3 unidades, es decir, vamos a movernos 3 unidades a la derecha
1, 2, 3 entonces "y" va a cambiar 1 unidad
cada vez que "x" cambia 3 unidades "y" cambia 1 unidad, y así no podemos seguir
3, 1 y ponemos este otro punto y podemos
hablar también para atrás
podemos decir que cada vez que "x"
cambia menos 3 unidades
"y" va a cambiar -1 unidad e inclusive
así nos podemos seguir
por ejemplo, si yo digo que "x" cambia 6 unidades
"y" va a cambiar 2 unidades
es decir, es proporcional menos 6 unidades en "x"
menos 2 unidades en "y"
esto es lo que nos dice la pendiente, y entonces ya tenemos bastantes puntos
y la unión de todos estos puntos es la gráfica de esta función que es una línea recta.
¡Y ya está!